yeah they're number of things that are
really great about Stanford that I think
are different from other places one idea
is this kind of open entrepreneurial
spirit that pervades the university
sometimes that's associated most with
starting companies but I think the same
attitude applies to research that people
are open-minded and looking for new
research ideas and so when a new
opportunity comes along we all try to
figure out how we can best take
advantage of a new opportunity and look
at look at new problems in the computing
area it's really the best place on the
planet really we have a good University
the best students in the world clamoring
to get in and really a short drive away
from most of the leading companies
there's an opportunity here both to look
long term at research problems but also
to get input from companies and other
organizations locally to try to get a
good mix you know my favorite thing in
research is to find a problem that
everybody can understand problem whose
solution is valuable but also there's
something deep in scientific and
challenging for students in going from
the problem to its solution computing is
a really great field for that there's
the very deep mathematical technical
issues but also where you know on the
front page of the business section a lot
and so there a lot of things that are
relevant accessible but also
scientifically deep and I think the
interaction with companies helps here
and also being a long-standing
established research university means we
have the time of the infrastructure and
the value is placed on good science so
it's perfect mix for me
with a couple of different levels one I
think is that by talking to people I get
an understanding of what the trends are
and what the interests are so at the
beginning when planning a course or a
lecture on a topic the most important
thing probably that anyone teaching does
is figure out what they want to cover
and what they don't want to cover so
that's always informed by what's going
on what am i hearing about what people
are interested in and as part of that
often you talk with somebody in a
company and they'll say here's the
problem i have i can't figure this out
and the problem really is not just that
isolated incident but the problem
they're having is an example of a larger
kind of lack of our current technology
or lack of our current understanding
about something so i try to go from the
specifics to something general and then
use that to figure out what are
promising directions for research and
then the selection of what to teach and
what to cover in classes is also based
on kind of understanding
oh so security is an interesting and
important issue it's also in a sense
kind of an add-on no one buys a phone
because it's secure you buy it for some
other purpose nobody buys a laptop
because it's secure it's an additional
feature so the field of security really
involves understanding security
mechanisms how to understand the
security issues and how to add them or
integrate them into other projects so
one part of bringing security out into
industry and application involves
projects that help people become
educated both about security mindset and
mechanisms and also about other topics
as they evolve so that we can bring
security into applications where it's
needed